[Music]
I feel bad for him before bachelor Ari
lion Dyke jr. there was another leading
man who caused controversy in bachelor
nation I would never want my children
having a father like you okay now you
remember my season and I see all the
time that I spent with the girls
obviously you spent like 40 hours with a
girl total you know like total so maybe
you know he went out with her and then
he was like wow he's the other girl that
won I won
you know and that's why I guess he did
people are very mad and I feel like you
should be relieved because you had a
crown that was like the you know kind of
biggest jerk bachelor sorry you know
that I know I guess so great I thought
was pre C's 3 years ago but but I gotcha
I always remember what Nikki's dad told
me like if you're gonna propose to my
daughter you're 100% sure you're gonna
marry her and for me it was very hard
because I have a daughter and I was like
I think the same way as you do I hope
the guy that proposed to my daughter is
gonna marry her and right now I just get
need to get to know her better do you
think maybe our II shouldn't have
proposed these he had a relationship
before I know ever has it better that he
had a girlfriend that he broke up with
to go on the back taking your crown he's
like smash me smash me I love you can
you be in love with two people at one
time
[Music]
I'll have to go back to in love and like
in somebody you know because we in
Spanish we are so many things that we
say before I love you we say take a
hotel or oh I adore you mean Kantas
which is a great word he said I love you
to two women before I will now say to
people I love you I guess that's just
not right
[Music]